[Music]
yeah I'm Chuck you can call me cherry or
my friend call me sherry so I come to
say hi with me later
also I want to remind you that you can
tweet and add PI data Amsterdam because
I think a great appreciation for the
organizers and all the volunteer is like
say thank you to them you can tweet
about all your amazing experience here
and then thank them so yeah this is me I
work as a data scientist at hotel bets
group so today I talk about the time
series in Toronto so it's like one of my
first project with them so it works so
oh yeah and I gotta talk about it later
and also I'm very actively organizing
some activities in London I came from
London I original I'm originally from
Hong Kong but now I'm working in London
so who of you is not living in
Netherland at the moment Wow it's very
you know international today is like we
have people flying from somewhere else
it's really great i love it and i love
python i love comedy I love being cheese
and I love truffle that's why I'm
talking about travel data and also
contribute to pandas I would recommend
you guys to contribute to an open-source
project because this is the best way to
give back to the open-source community I
think that's awesome yeah so this is a
company that the yes I said before the
project it's gonna be my first project
with them so we are global global
traveling business resource hotel rooms
from hotels and then we try to sell them
to other you know like travel agents
that you can find on the high street and
so we have lots of bookings worldwide so
well why is very important because I
will talk about that later so because
this is a beginner friendly talk so I'll
go to talk about the basics so bear with
me if you know a lot about time series
so what is a time series is actually a
sequential data what it means it's like
it's compared to other data that you
have
you can't you know mix it up the orders
because the order really does matter in
the time series so because the events
come in sequence right so you can't
switch it switch the order so it doesn't
make sense so and also it's something
that we when we handle time series data
a very common thing is like your absurd
am sample today's the data by you know
you want to see maybe are the maximum
selves of like of that day you don't
want to see like every single hour or
things like that or you want to see oh
oh how we doing last month so it's like
it's gotta be you know aggregated by
month so that's also something that we
will do with the time series and also
pandas that's wonderful cause like we
have we can set the index turret stage
time index so you can manipulate other
you know up sampling down sampling with
the day time index very easily so yeah I
love pandas also was special about
seasonal data why you like why we care
about them because they are a bit tricky
because they have a repeating pattern so
we can't just simply ignore it I will
talk about why later because when we do
the you know the trend and it you need
to take care about the period as well so
the cycle could be anything could be a
week a month or a day or a mix of both
mix of everything so it is quite tricky
and also some very usually we want to
compare the data at the same time in the
cycle for example in truffle you have a
high season low season right so if you
want to compare like how we doing this
month in the summer you will compare it
to some sometime in January like this
year or because it could be you know
people tend to travel more in the summer
so you want to compare maybe summer last
year so that's something that we need to
care about as well so this is not our
company's data is err positive but this
is a very common data set that you can
find is
open so you can find it online download
it and you know have a look at it study
it or do some modeling with it whatever
you like but I want to point out that
here you can see from the first picture
there is actual data you can see that
it's going up so it's like more and more
people traveling over the year and also
so that's that's the trend you can see
the blue blue line there at the top it's
like going up and also underneath if you
see that the value actually it kind of
like having a similarity like over time
so it's like the the same period happen
again and again and again so you can see
from the second graph you is like
there's a seasonality there from the
blue line that's the estimated US season
seasonality also you can see like a D at
the bottom you see that those things
like it's just noise it doesn't have the
seasonality it doesn't have the trend
because you can see like the mean of it
is more or less you know zero but it got
all these I up and downs life actuations
so they are there on the noise so
usually in a time series we will have
three things that we care about it's the
trend as I said like the top top blue
line that is the trends because we want
to see for example in the traffic we
want to see always it's a very common
question right it's our business growing
is it like are we making more money or
do we have more customers so that's um
that's the trend that usually business
care about and also there's a sad like
seasonality like not just in travel
maybe like for other business they also
have the season Araki over the year and
also but we want to see about a noise as
well because that could have an impact
to the business I got to go through it
later goes in in this project we want to
find like if we have a public holiday
will it affect our business so that that
would be part of the noise because it's
none of the training of the seasonality
is what's happening in a short period of
time it's just one day there's a one-day
holiday so what's that yeah so as I said
seasonality is tricky so we have to
really combat it like
to decompose everything so we can study
the data so was this data that I have of
the companies about so we are a b2b
company so we our clients actually are
their business right so that's why I
said if like there is a public holiday
maybe like they if they're there they
have a shop on High Street maybe they're
shut for the business because it's a
holiday
everybody's going out enjoy the Sun have
a beer and so nobody go to work that
would affect the business and also there
is also very high seasonality if it's a
if it's a business that maybe the
weekday and a weekend will make a
difference as you can see see the shops
like on the streets you know they have
maybe more customers you know we can
because people they don't work in office
they can go shopping so we can we take
difference and also we are a worldwide
company as I said before it's very
important because different country have
different you know public holiday or
different seasonality like for example
Israel you know they the office hour is
from Sunday to Thursday so it's a bit
different from the other part of the
world and also maybe there's time
difference like for example like here
and the US there would be like six hours
different so it's like day and ice
almost like swap so social time
different so a business world wise kind
of the data could be quite noisy if you
don't separate at country by country and
yeah so and go public all of the
estimation so this is the case study I
talked about the workflow that like we
you know imagine we in the meeting room
think about or what we got to do next so
we have this data right it's travel data
we have like bookings from a clients we
want to sieve we have more business or
if it's there's a public holiday like
how much it will impact our business so
we want to think about what to do so the
first thing is yeah of course we need to
find a way to break it down into
different countries I said like
different country have different like
psychos different holiday time so we
have to take care of that and yeah we
have to time series we want to find like
the different cycles different seasonal
periods and also find a trend are we
doing better than last year and things
like that so also we will have to
compare the holidays and also we have
the the LCS I mean a lower control unit
and upper control unit so we have like a
band that we have to because of the
noise that we have it could be just
random right it could be just just so
happen today sunny so like we have more
business so this is nothing that's very
typically interesting but we want to
separate the the normal noise to like
something that really happens and have
an impact so we need to have the the
upper control unit and NOAA control unit
you need to kind of figure out if it's
beyond that for example like if it's
like for example say I said here I think
it's one point two eight standard
deviation it's like beyond that then
there's something difference going on
yep so we and we also want to make sure
that that's the holiday so we need to
find the calendar where why like is it a
holiday in India it's a holiday in the
u.s. so we need to know and most
importantly we want to see the impact of
that holiday right so we want to
calculate the the receipt or minus the
lower country unit which is like how
much it is beyond the normal range which
I will show it more clearly with the
graph later so this is the package that
I use because there's a lot of different
ways you can do like a time series
analysis you have a Rhema you have like
hot winters which is the most common one
but also I found this this package is
amazing it's like it's cozy is know and
the github lang is down there so you can
check it out what they do is like
because they don't do like a very simple
linear trending because as it is as you
can tell from name is built for the
seasonal data so usually the data is
like there
they have a psycho so you can't do like
a normal simple linear trending with it
because imagine you have a sine wave
right yes ups and the downs if you do
like a simple you know moving average
then it can f ratio everything right if
you choose the the average windows would
be matching the period that you can have
a constant trend which may not be
something that you want right so um so
that could be very dangerous so you have
to take care of the seasonality before
you can do or you need to do like for
example you need to apply a filter to
filter out the maximum minimum and so
you can have a more clear way to do the
trending so for this seasonal package
they use a media median filter for the
details you can also check their
documentation page also it take care of
the seasonality using an offset which is
the same approach as the hot winters
model if you have experience using it
and yeah and also that the period this
its period of a period a fridge to take
care of it so when it decomposed the
time series Tran right so it will take
the seasonal oh like off using the same
formulas hot winters or so it will but
yeah because like it's done
automatically you don't have to tell the
the package or like the library that
what seasonality you have you can
provide it but that's and also another
option they say its automated to
estimate the periods that you have as I
said like you can have a time series
that it's like impose of different
different seasonal you can have for
example like a week cycle and also may
be at the same time you also have a day
cycle as well because business have like
there's more business in the middle of
the day and at night their shops are
shut so you can have multiple cycles so
you want to take care of them or so
that's why this seasonals
it would do the estimation of the period
using a time domain approach what does
it mean is like it's
is to simplify it it is actually a
Fourier transform so it will estimate
and calculate what frequencies it has in
the data and but the drawback for this
approach is that it's quite low because
its order of n square I think people are
looking for it for something that is
less than that so it is but it's not too
bad I mean in my experience the date for
that 1/2 is not massive but it's we're
still working ok it's not too slow that
you have to run it for a couple of days
it's far it's only run like maybe half
an hour or no it depends on your compact
your data is but for me it's not not too
bad so this is the graph you can see
that the red circle there is what I'm
talking about because you can see that
the the line the the great brown-ish
line below that's the lower control unit
so everything within that that those two
parallel lines is - I'll call that the
normal range that's the band so I think
I choose it to be 1.28 and standard
deviation that's I I cannot like this no
formula telling you what to choose but
by try an error I figured I was like mmm
it's 1.28 and it meshes with the the the
data that I have before so it kind of
matches it the bass so I choose one
point to a standard deviation but for
different data set it could be different
so the you can see that there's a deep
there it's below that lower control unit
so that could be the harder impact on
that day if we have a holiday on that
date so you can see that the the picture
above there is a trend it's very gradual
for our data it's not like a drastic
cycle over the year but it still is
there's a trend and highly seasonal you
can see like it's crazy ly up and down
up and down the stairs cycle so taking
out the yeah so the original data is the
orange one so taking out the green one
the trend and also the blue one is the
one after the seasonality so it's
adjusted
so you can see we have the the purple
line there and with the control units
but as I said we need to double check do
we have a holiday right so what we do is
like very simple we just great data from
Google API so we compared to the Google
Calendar to see if we have a holiday we
also want to compare it to last year so
we scrape basically two years holiday
with this year and we have last year so
you can see like in the rate this is a
piece from the report that we have we
have a report that generate every day so
every day the the stakeholders they can
check if this an impact if there's an
impact why maybe we have a holiday
somewhere and they can double check is
it the same in the region so yeah so you
can see like we also report last year
like the Sunday over there so and also
we have the holidays this year like
Thursday I think yeah this week 30 is
quite quite some time ago like maybe in
February or something so this is a more
more clear graph to show that the red is
the bad rice negative more red it is
more negative is this the green one is
good so for Christmas time I choose one
week in December around Christmas so
that's a seven-day of data there you can
see that a lot of countries especially
in Europe or us or Australia their their
business is bad because holidays right
so like all clients you know they shut
their business and people spend time
with their friends and family so they
don't go online and book a holiday
because you know there is there having
already having a holiday there nothing
about the next one oh yeah this is this
is the day that they poke isn't is not
the day that they are traveling so it
means that the business in Christmas
there's nobody is booking during the
time like less people not nobody but
yeah that's people poking at the time
maybe Chinese New Year's Day opposite
you see China is like is
week holiday so they they don't do
business they don't book anything
because maybe they are ready on the
train to see the family so they don't
need to book at that time so yep so I
think that's the end of my presentation
because there's no more if you have
questions you can ask so thank you very
much and thanks potato thanks all the
volunteers thank you thank you very much
there any questions from the audience in
in a few slides back yes this one yeah
it seems like the purple line there's
still some seasonality left what's up
with that I'm gonna grab an extra
microphone by the way the purple line
right yeah actually it's not very clean
because what the package does is we've
estimated like for a society it's a time
domain run so it would estimate that oh
maybe we have seasonality for a week and
then for this and that and we try to
adjust it we're still not not not very
clean like in the human eyes we can see
oh maybe we still have like some up and
downs there that's why we need the upper
and lower control unit right because if
I ideally if it's not that clean and
like there's some seasonality rest it
would be you know like a mile cycle
within that the ban so this wise it
won't be like like that shop drop there
is this suspected holiday there yeah
that's me okay
I got an extra mic to also do less
walking so you in the back
hi what is your reasoning behind or how
do you to determine the upper and the
lower control unit I'm really curious on
how you determine that yep we have last
year's data so we just do some
experiment compared with last year's
data and also like do we observe the
same drop on the holiday like with the
drop that we picked up because at the
end of the day we still need to compare
it to the Google API the calendar that
we have so for this it's not telling us
that it's their holiday because we know
there is a holiday we have to go Google
API we have the calendar there it's just
that we want to see how how much this
drop is how much it impacts our business
so I want to know what kind of some
things of data are assumed you know for
this algorithm so one we can apply this
algorithm one we shouldn't when we can
apply it it I think for my case is
seasonal data of like people when they
book like it's the okay you like for
example the sex of January they're like
those those amounts of cocaine so we
have that but I think it can be
generalized to any like time series data
that it has a seasonality that you want
to take care of you want to discount
that seasonality behavior and effects of
it so you can actually it's not
necessary that like you look at all
these noise and like the job you can
actually for example you maybe you are
interested in the trend so you can kind
of apply this library to see what's the
trend in your time series data yeah it's
more general using the package it's just
that this is a use case that I did using
the library and like this is some tricks
that you can use to pick up the like the
the impact of the holiday and
but I diss libraries it's basically any
time series that with a seasonality you
can use it to look at different part of
the time series like Tran or the season
like this the cycle of your seasonality
and things like that I have a question
as well so what what makes this method
of analysis so different from other time
series analyses is it the fact that you
have multiple decompositions of the
trend so you can see both the trends the
seasonality and the residuals do other
times here analysis methods provide that
or is it this this unique for this
method yes there's also other things
that like for example s ARIMA that also
you know they have seasonality s and
take care of the seasonality in the
decomposition but i would say this one
is very clean it's very simple to use if
you you look at their documentation it's
everything it's very simple take care of
it for you in the background for EMA
maybe you have to you know do a grid
search to search for the seasonality
yourself but this one is just apply the
you know the time during approach to
take care of it so I think the advantage
of using is libraries for easy but of
course you can still use other like s
ARIMA to compare but it's just for my
taste this one is it's very easy to use
it's very simple and it take care of it
just give you free serious back and
that's it I can see this being very
useful I mean actually essential even
for doing some proper a bee testing
right when you're deploying a new
version of something you want to know
how is it performing in a real world but
yeah you want to see that independently
of all the other trends so I was curious
this is packaged also have something to
model say a step function in the data so
you can basically fit like do I see a
jump in performance here together you
know what while factoring out all the
other effects I think the step function
maybe you have to see what filter you
want to apply when it do the you know
the
the D trending in the seasonality
estimation I think you can kind of I
remember because I choose the spine
smoothing to kind of to filtered out the
maximum and the minimum but I think if
you look at the documentation you can
adjust it to apply different filters to
use maybe it could be use because is in
general is it's for time series right so
if it's a staff function I think you
have to be more careful with the filter
but otherwise is it should it should
work okay but you need to double check I
think it works all right thank you okay
any other questions from the audience
okay cool thank you very much for your
talk please give a warm round of
applause
[Applause]